[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and in the next half an
hour we'll be seeing what's making the
headlines with Whitehall editor from the
guardian Marina Mason and PR consultant
Alex Dean will be speaking to them both
in just a moment but first let's see
what's on some of those front pages
the telegraph is leading with a report
on hundreds of miles of overhead cables
and pylons being fast tracked to help
Britain meet its Net Zero targets
despite public opposition
meanwhile this Fury over taxpayer money
being used to fund organizations
fighting plans to remove Asylum Seekers
to Rwanda that's according to the Sunday
Express
and the Daily Star features a piece on
Britain's impending invasion of
alcoholic Hornet Hornets this summer
reporting that boozed up Hornets are set
to Rampage barbecues across the country
the Sunday mirrors leading with an
exclusive on the Stephen Lawrence murder
rock legend sir Mick Jagger is set to
marry long-term girlfriend Melanie
Hamrick at the age of 79 according to
this Splash on the Sunday people
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
codes you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by Whitehall
editor at the guardian Marina Mason and
PR consultant Alex Dean great to have
you both with us thanks so much for
joining us a real mix of Stories on
tomorrow's front pages but certainly one
story that's going to feature a lot is
what is going on in France and the
Sunday Telegraph is talking about
President macron deploying Special
Forces to deal with these rioters ruina
certainly it seems to be a problem that
he has not got a grip of yet
yes that's right the writings entered it
it's fifth uh fifth night and macron has
got to be seen to do something more to
uh uh to address some of the criticisms
that the police have leveled at him
um and uh and the the public seeing this
uh violence on the streets
yeah and Alex your thoughts on this
story uh certainly you know protests are
nothing new in France but it certainly
does feel um rather different this one
they have seen these sorts of Rights
before with simmering tensions with the
police for decades now
you're absolutely right but this is the
worst for about 20 years of course the
French have a different tradition to
civil unrest to us and whilst we get
angry with our government quite often we
seldom go out and set far to our town
hall or things like that which have been
happening for a little while but this is
taking it to a whole new level and Louis
XVI in 1788 found out that it's not
always a good idea to put troops on the
streets it led to the collapse of
monarchy in France and his own execution
um you know there are reasons that we
don't generally use Armed Forces for
policing operations it's because the
Army is for fighting and when you put
the Army on the street it tends to do
what it does so it has to be a real
extreme when this happens but many
people will be looking at what's
happening in France and saying if not
now then when because it seems to be
going on and I can't help but notice one
of the latest things that happened
um is the radar gun store was a shop
that held a number of firearms which
have now found their ways into the hands
of looters so it really does look bad in
France at the moment yeah and Rowena
certainly a number of social issues uh
at the root of all this and president
macron has actually abandoned uh that
trip to Germany uh tomorrow to now stay
at home and try and deal with it
that's right this uh period of writing
was kicked off because of a incident
where police shot and uh killed
um a young man in a car
um and this is uh inflamed racial
tensions social tensions
um it is reminiscent in some ways of the
2011 riots that we had in the UK and
that were triggered by
um police the police killing of Mark
Duggan so um there's a lot that macron's
gots on his plate here he's going to
have to address some of the deep-seated
unhappiness that
um many of the young people who are
going out and writing are expressing
um at the same time as trying to get the
situation under control and deal with
the fear that people are feeling because
um areas of Paris and spreading
something as other areas across France
um they're seeing towns and cities being
looted and and
um and vandalized
um so it's really a very difficult
situation and um it as you say macarons
had to change his plans not go to
Germany and and try and get this under
control
yeah and Alex a final thought uh from
you on this story before we move on
certainly
um a lot of these social issues and
simmering tensions are in the the bond
the uh the the suburbs as they're known
of these cities in France where uh the
French government built this you know
these big expanses of social housing
after World War II and certainly they're
now home to a lot a lot of uh
communities uh of immigrants or or
second third generation uh immigrants
who just feel that they don't have the
same opportunities and police tolerance
certainly seems to be a real problem in
terms of brutality
or you've put it very well and of course
I say on the face of it because there
will be an investigation and we'll learn
more facts about it but on the face of
it what the policeman did to trigger
this was absolutely unforgivable I mean
just disgusting Behavior it would seem
um from the facts that we know so far
but this is a deep rooted and
deep-seated issue it's not about one
incident it's long-standing and it's
about a problem that the French have had
culturally and in assimilating people
that have come to their country it was
under our last government when Britain
was being told it had something to learn
from the French that Peter mandelson
then in government said if the French
social model is so great why are the Bon
Liu on fire and yeah that was its full
two decades ago this kind of social
unrest I think for all that we get wrong
in the United Kingdom can make us look
at our society and think we've done
something rather better in assimilating
newcomers than our neighbors but that
said my gosh we've got to wish them well
and hope they get a handle on this
yeah and certainly the rise the far
right has not helped with these tensions
in France let's move on now front page
of the Sunday Express uh Rowena
um their headline leading with the
controversial Rwanda policy uh saying
the Rwanda scheme is being foiled by one
and a half billion pounds of taxpayers
money uh elaborate please
well what it's saying is it's done a
toss-up of some of the funding that
Charities
um who are supportive of the uh the
legal challenge against the government
have received from the taxpayer
um but what what some of those Charities
and other critics of the policy uh might
say is that their challenge has actually
been Vindicated judges have found
um against the government and found that
it breached um article three of the echr
and that it wasn't a safe move to send
Asylum Seekers to the country so
um there is there is an argument on the
other side that this legal challenge has
been Justified as
um the country tries to figure out
whether this policy was within the law
or not and of course there will be a
challenge the government's fighting it
very hard and Richie sunick has staked
uh his Premiership on it partly because
he said that one of his five priorities
is to stop the stop the boat stop small
boats coming across the channel at the
moment it doesn't look very likely that
he's going to manage to achieve this
before the next election yeah and Alex
it's interesting isn't it that even
given the ruling at the court of appeal
this week that
um shipping migrants off to Rwanda would
would be unsafe it seems the government
are going to pursue this to the Supreme
Court it's not just an unpopular policy
but certainly for many it doesn't seem
practical either that they're pursuing
this headline policy that perhaps may
never ever happen
well part of the the point I think the
difficulty that you've seen as a result
of these challenges means that the
government is incentivized to continue
to pursue it because if you scrap it and
go back to step stage one if you go
right back to step one then it's all too
plausible that the next thing you put
forward will face a series of challenges
and hurdles as well but I must say my
own view is the challenges like this
from the dear old Express are rather
misplaced actually this is what the
courts are for for arbitrating and
hearing disputes and adjudicating on
what the law says and if a political
party if a government doesn't like what
the court has ruled about what the law
currently is then if you've got the
ability to change the law in Parliament
if you've got the strength in the
majority to put a new law in then you
should change that law it's not it's
really I think misplaced to criticize
the court for arbitrating on discussions
and ruling on what new policies are and
whether or not they are lawful that's
really what the courts are for and in my
view I suppose too it in the end I'd
look at this decision and say it's a
classic example of where the government
should appeal well within its rights to
appeal it was a split decision from the
court of appeal chief law chief justice
going one way his colleagues going uh
the other that's exactly when the
Supreme Court should be called upon to
give its ruling but For Heaven's Sake
let's not say that because lawyers
sometimes Give opinions you don't like
we shouldn't have them in the end the
rule is the law is there to protect all
of us